BOB HARRIS: Thanks, Jay.
[APPLAUSE]
JAY: All right.
BOB HARRIS: Give
it up for Jay.
Give it up for Jay, everybody.
Ah, Jay.
Hi.
Thank you for being here.
And if there are any technical
problems during the course of
the presentation, I'm the
only one here who
doesn't work at Google.
It's my fault.
Anything that goes wrong,
it's all on me.
Just know that right
from the start.
I just want to take
a second to just--
let's just look at this young
lady for just a second.
Now, we're incredibly good as
human beings at just glancing
at somebody else and getting
a vibe of who they are.
Somebody gets in the elevator.
In about 15 seconds, you wind
up making some sort of
judgment that if you were to
talk to them for an hour, 80%
of the time, you actually have a
pretty good sense, just from
body language and stuff.
And this woman could
have been a--
depending on how the birth
lottery works out, could have
been a grad student somewhere
here, or maybe she's the lady
who takes your blood in the
hospital, or she's the doctor.
Or who knows?
She could be anything.
Unfortunately, this
is in Cambodia.
She's standing in front of
her home near Siem Reap.
That corrugated tin
is her home.
And she works insane hours.
I doubt-- and I know people at
Google work really hard hours.
I doubt there's anyone in
here who works longer
hours than she does.
At the time I met her, she's 29
years old, married to a guy
the same age.
Between the two of them,
they have four jobs.
She has a roadside kiosk where
she sells gum and sundries and
so on to passersby for about six
hours in the morning, and
then she goes in and works a
full-time job as one of the
people in the tourist hotels,
the fancy ones near Siem Reap,
where tourists come and go and
take the big tour of the
Angkor Wat.
And the little kiosk that she
has is funded with microloans.
And she makes a small but
regular profit at this kiosk.
And with that and her husband's
jobs and so on,
they're trying to
build a life.
She's not getting rich doing
this, but it's helping her
build her life.
It's really cool.
And I was honored to-- when I
met her, she opens the door,
says, hey, come on in.
Super cool.
I sat down on the carseat, the
front car seat that's the
couch on the porch.
And we hung out and had
a wonderful day.
This was actually very typical
of a lot of the people I met.
Now, I want to back up a little
bit and give you just a
quick thumbnail of how
I came to this.
I want to make it really clear,
I don't work for Kiva.
I don't speak for Kiva.
They're just a charity I really
like, that I've written
a book about.
And when I first came in the
front door, I really didn't
know, does this work?
Is this great?
Is it wonderful?
What am I getting into?
And I found a lot of good stuff
here, but I want to tell
you a little bit about
myself, too.
The main thing that I--
I have had an insanely
lucky life.
I won every lottery
there is, I think.
I grew up middle class,
don't get me wrong.
But I've gotten to do
stuff like that.
And I wrote for "CSI" and for
"Bones." And I've done TV.
And I've made aquatic friends.
And I've had just a wonderful
opportunity to go
out and see the world.
I've kissed the Blarney Stone,
a couple times, actually.
It and I got on real well.
I've rocked the actual kasbah,
which is, it turns out, a
really great place to play beach
soccer, which is neat.
The countries in red are
the ones I've had the
opportunity to visit.
As you can see, I
suck at Africa.
I need to catch up there.
Central Asia is a definite
weakness.
But I've had the opportunity
to see the world.
I was a travel writer
for a while.
And as you travel enough, I
mean, on the surface, there's
like all these different
cultures and languages and
customs and so on.
But eventually, and maybe it's
just user fatigue from the
world or something.
But for me, as I watched people
playing their music and
hanging out, it just turns into
this beautiful pageant of
people where stuff that looks
different on the surface all
starts feeling like a coat of
paint you could scratch off
with a fingernail.
I mean, the truth is,
everybody's just trying to put
food on the table.
Everybody's just trying to
take care of their kids.
I mean, we're in Santiago,
Chile, in this photo here, and
these are Goth kids in Santiago,
Chile, who are
demonstrating how different they
are from everyone else by
dressing exactly like
Goth kids in every
other part of the world.
That's kind of a wonderful,
isn't it?
So I don't know what those
guys were doing.
And we blow on our blowers,
and we ride around on our
giant contraptions, and we
dance, and we play, and we
beat each other up.
And it just turns into this--
just, I don't know, festival
as I was traveling.
I just wound up making friends,
like every single
place I ever went, over and
over and over and over,
including places that I just
didn't think I'd necessarily
be welcomed.
This is Egypt in 2004 as the
United States was invading
Iraq, and the Middle East
was supposed to
be very, very dangerous.
And there's anti-American
sentiment.
And I got gang befriended just
walking around the streets of
Alexandria.
People would find out I was an
American, and they didn't
blame me for what the American
government was doing because
Egyptians have some experience
with the government not doing
what they want it to do.
So they didn't blame me
personally, and I was just
gang befriended everywhere
I went.
Put microfinance aside.
No matter what we might talk
about with Kiva or whatever,
if you have to leave, if there's
any takeaway that I
would want people to have from
this, it's that if you walk in
with an open heart, you would
have been befriended exactly
the same way, too.
It's a cool planet.
There's a couple of dozen
dangerous places that I
wouldn't want to go to, but
just a couple of dozen.
And at the end of the day, we
knock off from our job.
We put our arm around
somebody we love.
We take good care of our
children, and we go home.
But that view of the world
is not one that's
very common in America.
This is in Australia.
These are actual paid cricket
seats at a cricket match.
Not the best seats I've
ever been in.
There's a thing-- that big wall,
it's a sight screen.
It rolls back and forth.
It's so that the batter on the
other side of the wall has a
clear background
as the pitch--
as the boulder delivers
the ball.
And they'll roll it right
in front of you.
If the batsman needs it
there, it's there.
And suddenly you can't see.
And for me, this is very much
a metaphor for watching
American news when it broadcasts
about-- when it's
talking about international
affairs.
You really can't see much if
you're watching American news,
because the rest of the
world is blowing up.
It's on fire.
There's bad things happening.
People are oppressing each
other in the streets, and
that's kind of all you see.
You don't see all that wonderful
stuff I just showed
you, which you, your own
experience, I'm sure as you
travel, you have the same--
a very similar experience.
This is what we get in the
media, is fresh wave of terror
feared, which is an actual
headline in Belfast.
And I have to tell you, how do
you not fear a wave of terror?
It's a wave of terror.
You'll fear it.
I mean, it's kind
of hardwired.
And by the way, does Belfast
in Northern Ireland really
need alarmism in the media?
Is that helping?
Do they really need that?
So anyway, in the course of all
of this crazy luck that
I've had, in 2008, I lucked out
some more, and I wandered
into a job doing
luxury travel.
I worked for Forbes Traveler,
writing reviews of the finest
accommodations on Earth.
Now, again, let me back up.
I'm middle class.
My dad worked for General Motors
for 37 years, came home
exhausted at the
end of the day.
My mom worked in a
five and dime.
My grandfather was
a coal miner.
I can go full Loretta Lynn
on you if you need.
And suddenly, I'm jetting around
the world, going to the
South of France, to the English
countryside, and I'm
eating things I can't
pronounce.
And it's my job to walk in
with the white glove.
And I kept waiting every second
for some waiter to
just, no, sir, you are
not part of this.
And it was fun.
It was super fun.
So my byline winds up on things
like, "Europe's 50 Best
Hotels." I didn't even have
to choose the hotels.
They'd already done it for me.
I just had to show up
and verify that
the beds were comfy.
And I'd write a little piece
saying, yep, beds don't suck.
That was my job.
I got paid to take the trip
of a lifetime that
people would want.
I went all over the
world doing that.
That's pretty cool.
But the thing is, it
gets really boring.
Because wealth without
purpose is
purposeless, kind of built-in.
And I was bored out of my
mind, surprisingly.
It took a few weeks.
Don't get me wrong, it
took a little while.
But after a while, it's
completely purposeless.
And I was just losing my
mind with the boredom.
I was seeing beautiful things.
I mean-- oh, I don't know
how that got in there.
This is another one of those
articles, "Italy's 25 Best
Hotels." It looks so much
like the other article.
You'd be bored just even reading
what I was writing.
I was bored writing it.
How many synonyms for
"comfortable" are there,
really, in the English
language?
There's just not much
you can do.
So I'm traveling around.
I'm seeing all this stuff.
And finally, I'm in
the Emirates.
And the United Arab Emirates,
as you know,
have a little money.
And this is the Emirates Palace
in Dubai, which at the
time, was the most expensive
hotel in the world.
$3 billion luxury
accommodation.
And I should tell you, that is
not the Emirates Palace.
That office building size thing,
that's the entrance
gate to the Emirates Palace.
I'm standing on the steps of
the Emirates Palace looking
out at the entrance gate.
It's actually best viewed
by one of your
products, Google Earth.
The triumphalist entrance
gate, that's this little
building right here.
That's the Emirates Palace,
which actually has as much
floor space as the Pentagon.
There's a kilometer of private
beach and they have--
it was insane.
And this is where heads of
state come and stay.
And by the way, the
beds are comfy.
It was a fantastic time.
Now, you can live in this kind
of wealth and feel fairly
stable and guilt free and so
on in the South of France.
You don't have poverty
right in your face.
You don't see the
rich and poor.
But in the Emirates,
it's right there.
This is a couple days later.
I'm in Dubai.
And who's building
these places?
Essentially, indentured
servants.
It's people from South Asia.
There's some Southeast Asians,
East Africans.
And they're getting paid at the
time, depending on whose
reports you're believing at
the time, $6 a day, $7,
whatever, to work 12-hour days
in 105, 110-degree heat.
And then they're shuttled off
back to camps in the desert
that aren't even on any tourist
map or whatever.
They're just totally
hidden away.
And they're the ones building
all these magical, wonderful
paradises that they'll never
see the insides of.
And my dad worked
his butt off.
And Cleveland, where I'm
from, doesn't get
as hot as the Emirates.
But if the guy had worked two
shifts in a 12-hour day, and
it was 90 and humid, and he's
sitting on the front steps of
our house when I'm 12 years old,
and it's a hot August.
And he's sitting there with a
beer in his hand just trying
to rally himself for another
goddamn day of this.
I remember just-- you're a kid,
and you can just remember
being around it and how
painful that was.
And I looked at these guys, and
I don't know why it hit me
here of all places,
but it did.
I couldn't not see my dad.
And then I find out that the
reason they take these gigs--
and they' ve got to go and stay
for years at a time on
their contracts--
is because they can send of that
$6 a day, maybe $3 a day
home to Nepal, or to India, or
wherever they're from, and
help take care of their kids.
They're in this hell because
they love their families.
How am I going to take this
money that I'm getting paid by
Forbes and just put it in my
pocket, and fly home, and go,
well, that was spiffy?
How could I do that?
I got to do something with it.
So this is where I kind of
decided that I needed to-- and
I'm seeing the world.
And there's parts of the world
where that's a real modern
thing you'll see.
It's like a trip back in time
in some parts of the world.
And I was seeing kids
like that in India.
And I just-- "Changed Priorities
Ahead." That's a
real sign, by the way.
That's at Gatwick Airport
on the way out of
the rental car counter.
And sure enough, the guy in that
black car up there pulled
over and started spending more
time with his family.
So it's a real sign.
And I passed through
that sign, and I
needed to do something.
And Muhammad Yunus had won
the Noble Peace Prize.
That got my attention.
And I'm thinking about
these guys and
thinking about these guys.
And I came across Kiva.
Kiva, as you know, is
a web platform.
It allows people to support
microlending by putting money
in that supports the loans that
have gone out to people
in the field, small
entrepreneurs.
But does it actually work?
Does the money actually
get there?
Does it actually make
any difference?
That's a big question.
That matters.
And there's been some
controversy about that.
There's been some questions
about that.
OK, well, I'm a writer.
I need a job.
What can I do?
I went out to go look.
I wrote a book.
Let's go out and go
meet some clients.
Let's meet some clients,
shall we?
Our first contestant.
This is a lovely woman,
Zorka Yokich.
Now, by the way, meeting the
clients if you're a Kiva
lender, is not easy.
This is not--
MFIs are not travel agencies.
Microfinance Institutions.
This took time.
I had to-- and the book
goes into all of it.
Basically, Kiva didn't know what
the heck to make of me
when I showed up at first.
They get people all the time
saying, hey, I'd like to go
visit my clients.
And they're like, yeah, you and
a million other people.
But I just kind of stuck with
it, and I had a lot of travel
experience.
And I'm persistent.
And so a little bit of
the back story here.
The MFI--
the Kiva partner in Bosnia and
Herzegovina at the time was a
branch of an international
women's organization called
Women for Women International
that do amazing work in some
of the most difficult
environments in the world.
They're in Afghanistan and
Rwanda and Bosnia.
And I mean, you name it.
You look at their website,
Women for Women.
These people rock, right?
And so in Bosnia,
after the war--
and without getting into
anything grim.
But if you know what happened
during the Bosnian war, some
of the incredibly violent,
horrible things that were done
to women during that war, the
women of Bosnia need--
there's training and education
and personal support.
Some of these women don't
even have counseling.
And just going to a Women for
Women meeting is the first
opportunity they've had to sit
in a room together and cry, or
talk, or be hugged.
I mean, they do amazing stuff.
And microfinance is just
one aspect of what
Women for Women do.
So I'm sitting in the office
in Sarajevo with this
wonderful woman Seida who
runs Women for Women.
We're talking about this
whole project.
And I mentioned--
and at this point, I'm kind of
thinking, I don't know if I'll
ever even meet any clients.
And I mentioned that I've made
some loans through Kiva to
some of the clients.
And she goes, oh,
you have names?
And she's just going to
hook me right up.
And I'm like, well, yeah,
I can tell you
who I lent to, sure.
here.
The next day I'm in a car.
I drive up to Tuzla.
Unlike Hillary Clinton,
I didn't
make a corkscrew landing.
I drove to Tuzla.
And the next thing you
know, I'm sitting on
Zorka's front porch.
And she reminds me a heck of a
lot of my own mother to tell
you the truth.
And as you can see, she's
in the pig business.
She buys them and finances the
large expenditure with
microloans, then brings
them back, cuts
them up, sells them.
She also has poultry and
does some other stuff.
And so we're sitting on her
porch, and we're having
coffee, and we're hanging out.
And in the course of the--
I'll show you this
is me with her.
She was smiling the
whole time.
When we took out the camera--
and this was really common.
People's teeth aren't very
good in a lot of
parts of the world.
So when you whip out a camera,
they kind of close up the
mouth a little bit.
But she was a total sweetheart,
I promise you.
And she's bugging me
to call my mom.
When was the last time you
spoke to your own mom?
I get out the phone.
I call my mom.
Mom, hi, I'm in Bosnia.
Yeah, Bosnia.
Yeah, look it up.
Yeah, anyway.
So we're sitting there on the
porch and we're a short drive
from where, in the living memory
of everyone on that
porch, massacres had taken place
between Catholic Croats
and Bosnian Muslims.
And we're sitting on the porch
and Women for Women
International is run primarily
by Bosnian Muslims.
It's almost entirely
Bosnian Muslims.
It mostly serves the Bosnian
Muslim community.
My translator was a Bosnian
Muslim named Isla.
So I assumed she was a Bosnian
Muslim, forgetting the giant
pig in her Kiva photo.
So I just assumed she's
a Bosnian Muslim.
And so I speak--
I ask some question that
presumed Islam.
And Isla, my translator, turned
to me and without
translating, she said, Bob,
she's not a Muslim.
She's is a Croatian.
She's Croatian Catholic.
Oh.
Oh, well, let me rephrase.
And we continued on.
But the thing is-- and
this is some of the
tragedy of the war.
It's really hard to even
tell who's who.
They kind of have to
self-identify.
And so then we went
on with our day.
And I'm sitting there marveling
at the little bits
of business that are
starting to knit
together the community.
This is something that doesn't
show up in research studies.
It doesn't show up--
how do you quantify this
academically, that people can
sit together and money brings
people together like this?
Another microfinance institution
there in Bosnia
named Partner I visited.
They're not a Kiva partner.
But one of their executives
told me--
and sometimes when English
is your second language,
sometimes you have to speak
simply enough that wisdom
comes out almost accidentally.
And she said, Bob, the money
has no religion.
And I thought that was kind of
a cynical thing to hear.
But then as I'm sitting on the
porch with Zorka, and they're
doing business with each other
regardless of religion,
regardless of ethnic tension--
oh, wow, that's incredibly
useful.
That's really good knowledge.
OK.
So that's one of the little
side effects.
And this isn't something you'll
learn on the Kiva
website or in any of Kiva's
literature, or whatever.
This is something you had
to actually go and
physically sit to see.
And there's a bunch of
this sort of stuff.
Let's go to the Philippines.
I'll take you around
the world.
We'll do a travelogue.
This is a woman named Jennifer
whose loan I financed through
Negros Women for Tomorrow
Foundation in the Philippines.
And Jennifer is on the island
of Seibo, which is kind of a
boom town island.
If you make a phone call to--
jeez, Cathay Pacific, I think.
Or I'm not sure.
Like a lot of airlines, their
call centers are in Seibo with
people on the phones.
But you get out of the main
town, and you're just out in
rural villages again.
And Compostela is one of
those rural villages.
And this is what they call
a sari-sari store.
It's a convenience store that
she runs out of her own home.
Again, talk about work ethic.
There are images of the poor
that we have so deeply
ingrained in American society,
that poor people are lazy or
they're unmotivated.
Or that poor people are
uneducated or aren't
interested in educating
themselves.
Or that poor people--
whatever.
And then these stereotypes all
explode the minute you go
spend time with working poor
people here and overseas.
This woman works harder than
probably anybody I ever met.
And what I'm going to tell
you I still have
trouble believing myself.
I had to ask the translator
three times to make sure I got
this right.
The story I got, and that
everyone there was telling me.
This woman, she lives
next to a quarry.
And so her business is primarily
selling to the
workers from the village who
walk past her home on their
way to work in the quarry.
And so as they're going to go
by and have their breakfast
starting at dawn, so they're
going to be wanting to eat
around 5:00 in the morning.
That means she's got to be up
at 3:00 in the morning to
start cooking hot meals, which
she serves through that little
window there.
And she'll have 10
or 12 meals.
And when I was there, there was
still remnants of a lot of
these meals sitting out.
And she sells them a nice,
hot breakfast.
Now, some of them come later,
so breakfast is still being
cooked and served.
And then, some guys
are heading back,
and they need snacks.
Somebody needs smokes.
Somebody-- whatever.
So that convenience store keeps
operating, and she gets
a little rest in the afternoon,
but she finally
knocks off at about 10
o'clock at night.
That's a 19-hour day.
That's not even physically
possible.
She gets a couple hours in
the middle of the day.
Her mom helps her out.
OK, I can kind of see it.
I buy it.
And why do they do it?
Because of that little boy
there, that little boy with
his dad's head of hair.
That is the best hair on a
little kid I think I've ever
seen in my whole life.
I love that kid.
And that's when I went and
visited them there.
And that sari-sari store is
successful enough, largely
because of location.
Not every sari-sari is nearly
this successful.
It's a very common thing in the
Philippines, very common
business model.
That sari-sari store is doing
well enough that they were
starting to hire other people
in the community to act as
delivery people.
The business was expanding.
It was actually creating
other jobs.
Again, something
you don't see.
You just even as a casual user
of the Kiva website, you don't
necessarily see that.
It doesn't always show up in
academic studies because in a
whole village, how many
jobs get created?
But this is a very successful
example.
Here's a wonderful model.
This is in Kenya.
This is a guy named Symon.
And by way, it says ended with
loss, currency exchange loss.
The Kenyan shilling dropped
during the course of the loan.
I had $25 in the guy's loan.
I think I was down $0.14,
or something like that.
That's what that means.
Pretty trivial.
But Kiva billboards.
You lost $0.14.
So Symon here purchased and
insured a dairy cow.
This is my favorite form
of loan that I saw
anywhere in the world.
I love this.
This works.
There's a company called Juhudi
Kilimo in Kenya that is
a for-profit organization.
Not every Kiva partner
is not-for-profit.
Some of them are very profitable
organizations.
What they do--
and when I say very profitable,
I mean sustainably
profitable.
I don't mean they're
getting rich.
Don't get me wrong.
Juhudi Kilimo basically
pioneered the cow loan.
You know how we buy car
and we pay it off?
Suppose you're a cab driver, and
your car is your primary
business asset.
And after you've paid it off in
five years or however long
your loan is, now you own the
car free and clear and you can
use it to make a profit.
Now, the native cows in Eastern
Kenya are desert cows.
They don't really create
a lot of milk.
You can't have a dairy.
But if you live in the highlands
in the middle of
Kenya, which is great dairy
land, cows are rock and roll.
They're fantastic.
Bring in a good Western Guernsey
and that cow, you can
use the milk.
You can produce so much milk
that in the first year, you
pay that cow off.
And then you've got that cow
free and clear, creating
income for as long as
that cow lives.
And they even fold
a little bit of
insurance into the loan.
This produces wealth.
And they have a whole
pattern set up.
You get one cow.
Then after that cow, your second
purchase is what they
call a zero grazing unit, which
is a means of sustaining
and feeding and caring for the
cow without needing a giant
amount of pasture.
And then you get the second
cow and on and on.
They've got this whole path
set up that really works.
I met a bunch of cow farmers
in Kenya, and they talked
about their cows
the way that--
like if I showed off a Ferrari,
that's kind of like
how they were showing
off the cow.
They were so into this.
That cow's name, by the way, was
Grace, I believe because
she has none.
This photograph does not
capture the amount of
staggering and struggling that
was required in order for
Symon and Jen to get that
particular photo.
And that cow loan is
really working.
Now, this brings up
other problems.
Success means you have new
and different problems.
If everybody's producing dairy,
well, crap, now we've
got a lot of milk.
What do we do about that?
Now you got to develop a better
dairy supply. chain.
And sure enough, Juhudi Kilimo's
working with that.
And they're working
with the Kenyan
government to get that done.
But that's a great sign.
So this stuff is, frankly,
honestly amazing.
And some of these folks
know what they're
doing so well that--
this guy was so ingenious
that I frankly--
I was tempted to--
I joked when I was there
that I'm going to
ask him for a job.
And it's looking like less
of a joke sometimes.
This particular Simon--
this is also in Murang'a, Kenya,
same place, same loan,
same company.
He actually financed cows
because he put together enough
cows to get cash flow in order
to finance his coffee
business, which he just needed
seed money for the coffee.
This guy had a whole plan.
And I've been in touch since,
and it's working kind of
beautifully.
So he's got increasing
amount of land.
Anyway, I could bore
you with all these
different little details.
The most important stuff,
though, is that kind of
personal connection thing.
And I want to share with you
something that I learned as my
biggest takeaway from
all of this stuff.
Because the fact of the matter
is technology's changing
constantly.
The way microfinance is being
done is going to change
constantly.
People are constantly learning
some loan products
don't work that well.
Some work fantastically well.
Let's do more of those.
The technology is advancing
now in terms of mobile
banking, that even the means
by which it's done may be
radically different in
unpredictable ways in just a
couple of years.
So to get back to just human
stuff that I really want to
share with you and that's
ultimately the thrust of the
book, when I went to Lebanon--
I'm from a suburb in Ohio.
People from suburbs in Ohio are
usually just genetically
not comfortable.
I grew up watching Tom Brokaw
telling me that the Middle
East was a scary place.
Things blew up again today.
OK.
So I get a plane ticket.
I fly into the Beirut.
I've got a hotel reservation.
OK.
And I get to know the local MFI,
and they're lovely and
they're sweet.
Lebanon--
and things are getting bad
in Syria right now.
I don't recommend visiting
right off.
But I had an amazing
time there.
People were so welcoming
and cool.
And come have a party.
Come sit with us.
I have beer.
I loved it.
And one of the clients that I
met was this guy Hasan, who
has a little barber shop.
And when I went to college,
the idea of having--
being surrounded by Muslims in
Lebanon, one of whom has a
straight razor that he's going
to put at your throat, was a
terrifying thing.
This was wonderful.
He gave me an amazing shave.
We sat there.
Euro music was playing.
It was totally different
from any of my
expectations of how it was.
He was a wonderful guy.
And everybody I met, at
least in West Beirut--
I didn't get to see the whole
city, or whatever.
Younger people particularly
are so fed up with the
sectarianism and everything,
and they just really
appreciated that anybody
who could see
past all that garbage.
The welcome I got
was constant.
This isn't intended to be a
reading, but there's a thing
that I wrote on one page
of this book that is--
I said it better in the book
than I probably will ever come
up with it off the
top of my head.
So I just want to share one page
of the book, because it's
the most important thing I heard
in all of the travels.
And then we'll do
a little Q&A.
And by the way, I understand
that there was a guy here at
some point in the past, who was
talking a bunch of stuff
about how microfinance is bad
and evil and doesn't work.
And if there's questions that
came out of that, I'm more
than happy to address
any of those--
very happy to.
But let me share with you the
most important thing that I
heard while I was traveling.
Now, the people I was
visiting was--
Al Majmoua was the microfinance
institution.
And they facilitated
a bunch of visits.
And let me just vouch for
everybody they met as--
I mean, they were cool and
kind and creative.
It was actually the driver, a
loan officer from Al Majmoua,
that I met on one of the trips
that said the five most
important words that I heard in
Lebanon, and I, honestly,
am starting to think the five
most important words I've
heard in my whole life.
Now, Ahmed didn't always
work for Al Majmoua.
He enjoys it there very much.
And by the way, I'm going to
speak with a slight accent
here to indicate him.
I can't do a Lebanese accent.
I don't pretend to.
I'm just trying to designate
that it's him.
And the broken English is the
best that I could transcribe
in a bumpy car while the Three
Tenors are singing on the
radio while we're careening
around the Beiruti streets.
But to the best of my ability to
share with you, Ahmed says
he enjoys Al Majmoua.
"It's good.
Everyone equal, like family.
Christian, Muslim, everyone
love the same, you know?"
And the radio has got the Three
Tenors and then REO
Speedwagon.
And the radio is cycling through
and we're having a
nice conversation.
And Ahmed goes on to tell
more of his story.
"I asked God to bless
my family.
I am rich man.
Beautiful wife." He's got
two young daughters.
For 16 years, he had a large
and very popular
restaurant in Beirut.
And like a lot of Beirutis,
he stayed
completely out of politics.
I mean, like a lot of people
everywhere, all he's trying to
do is just make a really good
living and the politicians are
going to do what they're
going to do.
And Ahmed's restaurant
flourished, welcoming clients
of all faiths.
"Shia, Sunni, all same.
Television splits us.
Politics.
People love God, love each,
other, all same." He said this
I don't know how many times.
But in July 2006, Hezbollah
unilaterally launched rocket
strikes against Israel, and
they kidnapped Israeli
soldiers near the border.
And that touched off an
escalating conflict that
eventually led to Israeli air
strikes on Beirut itself.
And in one of those
strikes, Ahmed's
restaurant was destroyed.
Through no fault of his
own, his entire
livelihood was gone.
So now Ahmed works as a loan
officer at Al Majmoua,
rebuilding his own life while
helping others to do the same.
And to help put his daughters
through school, he also works
on weekends, but now in someone
else's restaurant.
He greets people.
He seats people.
He washes dishes.
It's a huge step down.
So I ask him if he's bitter.
I would be.
Somebody blows up my
house, I'm ticked.
If going from being the owner of
a restaurant to just being
the hired help, has that made
him angry at the Israelis, or
at Hezbollah, or God, or--
are you angry?
"No no, no," as if he was
talking to a child.
"Everything is clear for me.
When my God is with me, I don't
care about something
like that, no."
And he didn't pause here while
he was speaking, but in my
memory, he did because I've
thought about these next five
words, honestly, every single
day ever since.
The next five words that came
out of his mouth were this--
"You love more, you win.
You don't stop thanks for
God." And then again for
emphasis, "You love
more, you win."
Now, Ahmed didn't say that at
some yoga retreat in Berkeley.
He didn't say that in some
philosophy class or as some
abstract notion.
It's not something he learned
from a book, of any book.
It's just who he was.
It's what came out
of this heart.
And it was a choice he was
making every single day in
West Beirut after having
his life blown up.
And he could say it, and mean
it, and struggle with it in
the same moment, and then
resolve himself to do it
again, over and over
and over again.
You know, I don't think I have
anything in the world I'll
ever say as important as what
Ahmed said to me that day.
And so now I'll just try to
share that with you a little
bit and hope you walk out of
here carrying that with you.
So that's pretty much the
shindig about the book.
And this was spray-painted on
the wall in West Beirut.
This is one of the graffiti
right there in Beirut.
Somebody had put that up.
That's what, I'm sure, motivated
Matt when he founded
Kiva to be so passionate
about creating it.
I know that's where Kiva lenders
come from when they
are trying to reach around
the world that way.
That's why the clients are doing
it, is for their kids.
And even the people who are
critics of microfinance,
they're doing it out of concern
for the clients, too.
It's all coming from
a place of love.
And that's a really wonderful
thing to hang onto.
So anyway, that's pretty
much my spiel.
And by the way, my own loans--
you can look them up.
It's online.
You can poke around the
Kiva website and you
can find my own loans.
This is as of February.
My original $20,000, which was
the amount of money that I'd
put in, in February, it
had recycled around
almost seven times.
And it had worked out to get
repaid to me personally over
99% of the time.
Kiva-wide, it's 99%.
So it's pretty much as reliable
as a savings account.
I mean, how much money do
you get on a savings
account right now?
Like nothing, right?
You put it into a savings
account, you get like a
fraction of 1%.
So if I put $25 into Bank of
America, and then a year later
come back, I've get $25 and
a couple of pennies.
Or I can put it in Kiva, and a
year later, on average, I've
got $25 minus a couple
of pennies.
And for that price, this little
stack of pennies that
big, that money gets to be off
in Nicaragua helping some
bicycle delivery guy
or something.
That's a pretty good deal.
I'll go with that.
So that's part of why
I like this stuff.
So anyway, that's the spiel.
Thanks for coming
to work today.
[APPLAUSE]
BOB HARRIS: I'll set this
up for the cameras.
And if you guys have questions
or answers--
if you have answers,
please, bring them.
I'm more than happy-- if there's
a microphone or you
can just stand up and
squeal, whatever.
I'm happy to answer anything.
All right, we have our
first contestant.
Well, there are situations
where charity is
a much better option.
But it depends on
the situations.
I think for anybody--
I think when microfinance went
through its big vogue around
the time of the Nobel Peace
Prize to Grameen and to
Muhammad Yunus, and people were
talking in such grand
terms about how microfinance
is going to end
poverty and all that.
That, actually, only makes
logical sense if the sole
cause of poverty was a lack
of financing in a
lot of these places.
And if you've got an earthquake
in Haiti, you need
to bring in aid.
I mean, aid is like
the first and best
option in a lot of cases.
But if aid alone was the thing
that was going to change the
world, how much aid has been
poured into Africa without
careful planning, without
careful oversight?
Look, if you bring a bunch
of rice in, that's great.
But what about the
rice farmers who
were already there?
And all of a sudden,
you may have
driven them out of business.
Economic dislocation can be
caused by aid as much as it
can be relieved by it.
So what has to be done is--
what's most important more than
anything is actually the
ability to listen to the
local people and
say, what do you need?
And we, as Westerners, very
often kind of have this--
we're the ones who will figure
out and solve the problems.
When a lot of times, the folks
on the ground, they know
exactly what they need,
and you just ask.
One of the things that I found
most appealing about Kiva is
that Kiva is people saying,
OK, this is what
I want on my farm.
I want a cow.
It's not some guy from the World
Bank or from some big--
whoever.
Some foundation coming
in and saying, you
know what you need?
It's a giant hydroelectric
dam.
It's a guy saying, hey,
I want a cow.
This is going to fix things for
me in my time frame and
with my work.
And that sort of bottom-up
approach, I think is, at
minimum, equally as important
and I think probably much more
important than simply throwing
aid at a circumstance.
In my book, I even get into
circumstances that are really
quite famous, where people put
their money into a charity
thinking, hey, this is
going to be great.
And it didn't work out the
way that we'd hope.
You remember Live Aid and USA
for Africa in the 1980s, which
did wonderful stuff.
And to their everlasting credit,
that was the first
global event where you
really had people
all over the world--
anyone with a television--
aware of the ability
to reach out and
reach around the world.
That's an amazing cultural
impact, regardless of what
happened after that.
And they did save a very
large number of lives.
But the dictatorship in Ethiopia
that was largely
responsible for the problem--
it wasn't a weather thing.
It wasn't just drought.
There was a horrifying
dictatorship in Ethiopia that
was doing--
collectivizing the farms, which
we know what that did in
China and Russia, which was busy
essentially trying to put
down rebellions all
over the country.
They were the ones who wound up
being in charge of where a
lot of the aid went.
And while it saved some lives,
a lot of lives, and there's
different estimates, there's
also estimates, even at the
time while it was happening,
that it was also leading to
helping empower that
central government.
So I don't think it's ever going
to be fair for anyone to
just say, well, aid
is the answer, or
microfinance is the answer.
There's never one answer.
And I think it just needs
to be taken on a really
sophisticated level,
listening closely.
Experts from this part of the
world need to be listening to
the experts there.
That's my feedback.
Hope you enjoyed it.
Three positives about Kiva.
Well, one, I mean--
for me, the people in the
pictures are never just going
to be people in the
pictures anymore.
I mean, I'm in an exceptional
situation in that--
I mean, any time I lend to
somebody in Seibo in the
Philippines, I remember
the place now.
And if I don't know that
specific person, I know what a
sari-sari is.
So there's that thing.
There's a huge educational
component, too, that I think
is wonderful.
Schools are starting to use
Kiva in classrooms.
A kid gets involved
with it and--
I don't know.
I heard a story about
a classroom where--
I think there was some village
in Nicaragua that makes really
great hammocks.
And the kids in the class
we're like, really?
And they got really fascinated
with the hammock making.
And they, as a result just from
an extension of that, got
more interested in Nicaragua,
and then Central America, and
it builds from that.
You find one point
of interest.
So I think that's a really
wonderful thing.
Another wonderful thing, there's
these things called
lending teams they have at
Kiva, which are affinity
groups, self-selected.
The two biggest ones are the
Kiva Christians and the Kiva
atheists, who are essentially
having an ideological argument
over whether or not you need a
deity to foment generosity.
And so far, at least on a
statistical level, the
atheists are winning,
rather strongly.
And so the Christians get
right back in there.
And you know, if you're going to
have a theological debate,
this is one of the best
ways to do it.
It's a fight over generosity.
That's kind of wonderful.
And those lending teams can
be really powerful.
I didn't know how much.
There's a team on Kiva right now
that I can't take, really,
any credit for called Friends
of Bob Harris.
It's 1,100, 1,200 people--
I don't know the exact
number, who--
I don't know how
this happened.
They're the fourth biggest
team on Kiva.
They passed Team Europe.
They passed Team Australia.
We passed the gays.
We passed like--
so far there's the Christians,
the Atheists, and there's one
other team.
And then Friends
of Bob Harris.
And I'm just this dude.
I mean, that doesn't
even make sense.
And what it is, it's just a
very fun team that kind
gathered momentum.
There's a discussion
board aspect to it.
And people get on, and they're
playing with everything.
There's a spirit there.
These are just funny, charming
people who found each other.
And I'm just sort of--
I have very little
to do with it.
If there's a big thing of cotton
candy, sugar is just
swirling around, and somebody
puts a stick down in there,
and you come out with cotton
candy, I'm the stick.
But I'm not that.
I'm not that candy.
And so these people have the--
you go on the Friends of Bob
Harris team, and they just
decided to have a summer
road trip.
And so they went through all
these loans on Kiva finding
people who sold stuff that you'd
want to buy along the
side of the road, or people who
sold tires, or people who
sold anything related to
a summer road trip.
And that was how they
fundraised.
I had nothing to do with
that, but on it went.
And that team's raised $3.4
million in lending funds.
And I'm--
honored?
I don't know what
I am about it.
It's cool.
So those are three aspects
I would think of-- the
educational aspect, the
sense of connection,
and the social aspect.
A bad thing about Kiva?
There's a few things that I'd
like to see done differently,
to be honest.
The one thing that some people
point out is that you can't
see the interest rate for the
specific loan that you're
investing in.
That would be nice.
I can see how long it lasts.
I can see that it's
six months.
But I also understand that to
just put that number in a
vacuum, well, what's the local
interest rate comparatively to
what banks avail?
And then you got put
that information.
And what's the local
inflation rate?
OK, that information
has to be there.
And if you're going to have full
transparency, then you've
got to get into transparency
of context.
And that starts becoming
a really complex task.
But that's a discussion I think
that's worth having.
There's a couple of
other things.
There are kinds of loans that
I sometimes see that I think
need a little bit
better labeling.
For example, if you make a loan
into India, your money's
not coming back for three
years, even if it's a
six-month loan.
Now, they billboard that.
They put that up there.
That's really obvious.
Some of the educational loans
that can be up to 11 years.
There's a university
in South Africa.
I've seen a number of cases
where people made the loan,
clicked Lend $25, and didn't
realize they weren't going to
see that money back
for 11 years.
That's a tiny complaint,
really.
That's easy to fix.
They can go and fix that
and billboard that
harder by this afternoon.
So I would say that most of my
quibbles with Kiva are more
along the lines of quibbles
about information being made
maybe a little more
visible or usable.
That's my best answer.
Well, I should correct-- the
question if everybody could
hear it was the challenges that
the clients had before
they came to Kiva.
Well, they actually didn't
come to Kiva.
They go to their local
microfinance institution.
And when they walk in the door,
they may not have any
idea that Kiva even exists.
I mean, they don't know who's
funding that institution.
They're just trying to get
a loan to buy a cow.
And so when they walk in, then
the nice man that did the loan
thing, they say, oh, by the way,
your loan's going to be
funded with Kiva.
We need you to pose for picture,
and they do a little
bit of that stuff.
But for the clients themselves,
most of their
experience is primarily just
with the local microlender.
That said, on the rare occasions
when I did talk to
clients who were aware of Kiva
or knew that there was some
crowd funding aspect to their
loans, they love that.
They just think that's--
the idea.
I met a guy in Nicaragua, again,
who when he realized
that there were people from
like 20 countries who'd
invested in his business,
that's just like--
my god, that must feel cool.
As far as the challenges they
have beforehand, almost
everybody that I met had--
you got to scramble to make
a living here in the West.
I mean, everybody in here has
got college educations, and
we're all scrambling and
figuring out, god, what the
hell am I going to do?
I'm going to change my career in
three years, or I just came
from something else.
And if you're living at the $6
a day level, just multiply
that by a huge factor.
Everybody I think I met had
been in five different
businesses prior to the
one they were doing.
And maybe this one's working
now, so they're
sticking with it.
There were some-- and I mention
this in the book.
There were some where the
business didn't quite work
out, and then they try
something else.
There is kind of a humorous one
in the book where I met
this woman, who I called Mercy
in the book because I don't
want to embarrass anyone, who
made charcoal-flavored yogurt,
which is the local flavor.
It's Western Kenya.
It's the bark of a tree,
and it's the flavor.
And it tastes really like
charcoal-flavored yogurt.
And I had the intestinal
equivalent of an international
incident after consuming
this charcoal yogurt.
I think the next morning they
could hear me in Uganda.
And her business, strangely
enough, she didn't sell enough
of the charcoal-flavored
yogurt to
really stay in business.
Now she's OK.
Her husband's a cop,
and they're fine.
They're economically fine.
But I followed up afterwards
meeting clients.
Is this person still
in business?
Is this person still in
business, and so on to see.
The majority were.
Nobody was getting huge rich.
Some people were pretty
successful.
A lot of people were skating,
and there were a couple that
didn't work out, just like
everywhere else in the world,
really, if that makes
any sense.
All right, so let's hit
the Lend button.
It's pretty easy to find the big
giant green Lend button.
Oh, wait.
I don't know how much
I have to lend.
Do I have anything
in the kitty?
I didn't see it.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
BOB HARRIS: Let's see.
OK, all right.
That's enough for five loans,
if I don't tip Kiva.
I'll tip Kiva.
All right, let's make
five loans.
Where do we want to loan?
Here's a list of countries.
Is there anybody I haven't?
I haven't lent to
Thailand yet.
I keep looking to see if
Thailand comes up.
Somebody shout out a country.
We'll make a loan there.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BOB HARRIS: What was that?
AUDIENCE: Zimbabwe.
BOB HARRIS: Zimbabwe.
And I heard another one.
AUDIENCE: Vietnam.
BOB HARRIS: Vietnam.
Vietnam and Zimbabwe.
All right.
We'll click for Zimbabwe, and
we'll click for Vietnam.
And I'll close that.
And here's Zimbabwe
and Vietnam.
There's 33 loans available.
And OK, here's a woman who's
going to buy a greater variety
and quantity of pork
pies and salted
shredded meat to satisfy--
it looks like she's upgrading
her stock in an existing
established business.
This looks like somebody
who knows what
the heck she's doing.
I mean, I'm buying that
as a business model.
And by the way, I don't just
throw the money around.
I want to make sure that
they're doing stuff.
OK, these people are going
to buy winter clothes.
That's not really a
business model.
So I don't necessarily feel
like I'm investing in--
but at the same time, they're
trying not to
freeze in the winter.
So OK, this first Zimbabwe loan,
I'm feeling compassion,
not necessarily a business
investment.
But I'm OK with that.
If I think about it,
I'm OK with that.
Oh, already funded.
Interesting.
All right.
OK, this woman's definitely
all up into
the business thing.
Let's see who else
we got here.
New shampoo chair to better
satisfy her customers.
Apparently the one she
has is pointy.
So apparently she wants a
soft chair or something.
That's a functional business.
All right.
She's just reselling clothes.
You get a lot of those
businesses.
I haven't seen anybody like
really flourishing or getting
rich, but a lot of times, a lot
of loans wind up getting
used in what's called income
smoothing, which I don't have
a problem with.
Sometimes people have
problems with it.
Well, that's not really
flourishing as a business.
Income smoothing is where you
just use a loan to do exactly
like what it sounds like.
You smooth your income.
Maybe your income is
seasonal and--
anybody's who had credit cards
and had to juggle them knows
what income smoothing is, or had
to figure out, aw, jeez,
this month sucked.
I thought it was going
to be so much better.
I'll be better next month,
and you smooth.
And there's a lot of people
who criticize microlending
because, well, some people are
just income smoothing.
Yes, they are.
I'm fine with it.
OK, we'll hit her.
And let's see, is there
another Zimbabwe one?
OK, she makes bedspreads and
curtains and seat covers.
I'm in.
All right, there's
a bunch of loans.
OK, hit my basket.
And we're going to tip Kiva
$15 in the kitty for Kiva.
Continue.
Complete Order.
There, I just made four
loans that went to--
one to Asia, one to
Southern Africa.
Now, in full disclosure, those
loans already had been made to
the clients.
They're what they call
predispersed.
Clients already have
the money.
It's the only way the
thing can work.
Let's say, for example, that--
nobody is sitting around
waiting for me.
When is Bob going to send
that $25 to Zimbabwe?
I can't buy blankets
till Bob sends $25.
No, the way it works is that the
microlender actually gives
the money first, then
it gets refilled by
us on the back end.
And then from that point on,
it repays just like the
conventional bucket brigade.
That's the only way the
model would work.
If it was tried any other way,
it wouldn't be feasible.
And I like it that way.
One of the first loans I saw
on Kiva was for a guy named
Victor in Paraguay, who
was in the middle of a
dengue fever epidemic.
Dengue fever's a nasty
tropical disease.
I've had it myself.
It's not fun.
And it kills kids.
And it's mosquito-borne.
And Victor wanted to buy a bunch
of strips of leather and
some Citronella.
Dip the leather in the
Citronella, make anti-mosquito
bracelets for the kids,
sell them cheaply,
and kids don't die.
I want his loan funded
as fast as possible.
I don't want him waiting
around for me.
Does that make sense?
So that makes perfect sense.
So how long did that take?
That was two minutes,
three minutes?
Once you have an account,
it's very, very easy.
I want to make really clear, I
don't totally speak for Kiva
in my response.
I think I have an accurate
response here.
Bennett from Kiva's here, so if
I get something wrong, you
correct me.
Just jump right in.
Those go to operating expenses,
overhead, stuff like
that, to my understanding
of it.
And Kiva's annual report is
right on the website.
They're totally transparent
about where the money comes
from and where it goes.
And I don't remember exactly
what percentage of their
operating expenses come
from that 15% donation
along with the loan.
What is it?
BENNETT: Actually, that's 65%.
BOB HARRIS: 65% of the
operating expenses
come from the tips.
So without people doing those
tips, Kiva goes belly up.
Or Kiva, at least, has to
shrink dramatically.
So if I like Kiva, I should
probably contribute
occasionally to the operating
expenses.
Now, in all honesty to you,
I don't always do
it when I make loans.
Sometimes I'm just not feeling
that generous.
I have my days where I'm just
kind of like, yeah, you know.
And if you've been to the Kiva
office, it's not extravagant
in any way.
And actually, the salaries
of the--
I'm not going to disclose
anything here, but it's
publicly disclosed.
The salaries of all of
the senior staff are
in the annual reports.
Ain't nobody getting rich.
If I were to-- like after the
presentation's over, I can
tell you what you can find.
I've mentioned it to a few
people and they go, how does
anyone live in San Francisco
on that?
And that's the senior people.
By the way, Bennett, how
does anyone live in San
Francisco on that?
I mean, it's really not a ton.
So I don't see anybody
making bank.
I think the money gets
used pretty well.
I think that's actually a very,
very general question.
It's a little hard to answer
because of how general it is.
I think it would be much easier
to measure, OK, how do
we measure the impact of
the cow loans in Kenya?
I could answer that question
because there's going to
specific statistics about
a specific program.
How do we measure--
and then we could go into
lots of details.
And then to measure the impact
of Kiva, then we would have
to, on aggregate, have
all of that data.
I don't have it.
So to a certain extent for me,
you could argue that there's a
certain active faith
thing going on.
But in my case, I've actually
been in the field to a bunch
of these places, and I've
seen them working.
I've only been to a couple
places that weren't.
And they weren't Kiva
partners, so things
look good to me.
I think that the other way to--
one of the measures of
it, too, is that if it
wasn't working--
and this is also true of
microfinance in general.
When people talk about
microfinance as being
something that hurts the poor
or the real negative stuff
that's said, almost always--
I mean, I don't think I
can think of a case--
it's made as a grand statement
addressing not just a specific
situation, but then it's
overgeneralized
to the whole field.
Andhra Pradesh, India, horrific
tragedy caused by
microfinance institutions who
were much more concerned about
profit than they were the
welfare of the client.
Extremely clear, extremely
horrible, and the fact that
nobody's in prison over
that is an outrage.
But does that have anything
to do with
Juhudi Kilimo in Kenya?
No, just nothing.
And does it have anything
to do with Kiva?
No.
And some of this actually
is the problem of the
microfinance industry itself
has done this to itself by
using such inaccurate
terminology.
I would like to see the word
"microfinance" abolished from
the English language, because
it's such a broad term.
I don't know of any other field
of human endeavor where
one word is used to blanket
describe so many diverse
activities.
It's a word like sports.
If I say sports, am I talking
about baseball, football,
hockey, whatever?
Now those endeavors--
I'm going to rant here for a
second, but think about it.
Baseball, football, hockey,
basketball, they're four
completely different
endeavors.
But they're all done
for profit.
They're all done with a certain
demographic of people
for a certain demographic of
people, with a certain set of
advertisers.
They're the same exact business
model, and it's the
same exact people, just behaving
slightly differently.
And yet, we have very precise
words for those, and we would
never confuse something that
happened in hockey with
something that happened
in basketball.
Now let's look at
microfinance.
You have international
IPO things like
SKS that are massive.
And you have little places on
the corner in Nepal that are
actually funded out of
somebody's back pocket.
You have people who
are for profit.
You have people who are
not for profit.
You have people who are offering
education, and health
care and health training, and
AIDS awareness and all sorts
of different personal things.
And you have loan mills
that exists simply
to try to make loans.
You have a massively diverse
set of activities that have
nothing in common with each
other at all, except the
stated goal of ultimately
helping an end user who is
economically micro by
local comparison.
That's nuts.
But if we use that terminology,
inevitably when
something goes wrong in one
part of it, and it's
microfinance, everybody
catches the flak.
And that's part of the reason
that any misbehavior at any
part of the field gets
so generalized.
I don't know if that makes
any sense, but I hope by
addressing that just slightly,
that will help us think more
critically when people start
saying, and microfinance does
this bad thing.
Really?
Which part?
Which specific part where?
And then that becomes
a very important
next question to ask.
Did that clear anything up?
Yay, good.
Oh.
[APPLAUSE]